d'une première ce soir donc on va
rentrer dans l'univers des femmes
perdues et puis à travers la magie qui
opère de l'autre côté de cette arche
on veut vraiment que les gens rentrent
dans l'expérience nous voici dans le
monde devront imaginer par l'équipe de
mauvaise facture cet univers inspiré des
contes jeunesse prend vie à la tombée du
jour voire ghetto
bonne chance la fée vérité aujourd'hui
elle est complètement hallucinant le
säntis que traversent les voitures pour
se rendre jusqu'à l'écran du ciné parc a
été aménagé exclusivement pour
l'expérience
outre cette sont fixes sur d'éclairage
des effets spéciaux de la fumée on
rentre vraiment immersif
le photoshoot est vraiment intéressant
les gens arrivent devant la voiture pour
sortir de leur voiture faire une pause
après un bref passage au brome ou matin
les véhicules s'installe à deux mètres
les uns des autres
au programme huit courts métrages
d'animation provenant de la collection
de l'office national du film le tout
agrémenté d'effets sonores et lumineux
avec toutes les faits augmenté je pense
que ça va donner un autre dans l'autre
feeling on l'appelait impulsée par du
futur ce partenariat entre le ciné-parc
aux feuilles d moment factory est né il
ya à peine une semaine en pleine crise
de la coved 19,6 avait pas eu la
pandémie je pense pour quelque chose
comme ça serait arrivé on a commencé à
tout va du télétravail la pandémie il
est contre eux commencent à descendre
on a eu une questionnements les
partenaires chez moi même puis on essaie
de garder toutes les toutes les
employées par aucune mise à pied
on a lancé tout ce qui était possible et
sur des initiatives internes
c'est la première qui voit le jour
l'objectif était de créer un événement
rassembleur qui respectent les mesures
sanitaires
pour moi c'est un rassemblement social
dans un temps de distanciation ce
rassemblement qui permit pas ce qu'on
peut garder nos distances mais on peut
quand même socialiser avec des gens la
famille des amis
les premiers à vivre l'expérience passe
un bon moment
la riaa beaucoup dans la voiture les
enfants vraiment beaucoup les films
c'est divertissant même temps et de la
musique
c'est le fun de voir des gens moi je
trouve dans un cinéma de la petite tu
écoutes un film de plus le livre moi une
expérience avec le son il ya la musique
dans les arbres et la couleur tout s'est
vraiment c'est vraiment le fun rom sera
présenté tous les soirs jusqu'au 12
juillet si l'expérience est concluante
elle pourrait perdurer dans le temps et
même être exporté à l'étranger ici
marie-hélène rousseau radio canada
sherbrooke